can we just call this what it is it was
easier for your parents and grandparents
to buy a house that was their reality
the Market's different now it used to be
easier for families to live on a single
income yes it used to be easier to go
down the street and get a job at the
local Mill without a degree or yes you
want to be a fiction editor and live in
downtown Manhattan and yes you want to
own an organic farm outside of Orange
County or you just want to get a general
admission ticket to see Taylor Swift it
all feels so impossible the world got
really expensive for the time being it's
not going to change and becoming angry
and resentful and railing against the
system is like being super mad that it's
hot in Arizona it's not going to change
the weather it's just chafing against
reality the question is what are you
going to do now